à cause d'une faille informatique les
résultats de tests antigénique et
d'importantes données personnelles de
700 mille patients français ont été
accessibles à tous durant des mois sur
internet c'est une révélation de
mediapart qui part d'une simple
recherche innocente d'une patiente elle
voulait avoir accès à ces résultats de
tests antigénique sur le site communiqué
par son pharmacien elle s'est alors
aperçu qu'avec de simples modifications
dans la barre d'adressé de son
navigateur elle avait accès aux données
de centaines de milliers de patients nom
prénom date de naissance adresse numéro
de téléphone mails et numéros de
sécurité sociale le site en question
s'appelle france test il envoie les
mails aux patients et transmet les
résultats de tests qu'ovide à la
plateforme de l'état l'acide est réservé
aux professionnels
c'est cette plateforme conçue par
l'ap-hp qui permet de centraliser les
résultats et d'établir le traçage des
malades et des cas contacts mais de
nombreux professionnels de la santé l'a
trouvé difficile à utiliser avec leurs
propres logiciels il préférerait parfois
avoir recours à un intermédiaire qui
s'occupait de transmettre les résultats
des tests qu'ovide à la side up
française qui venait en aide aux
pharmaciens comptait 600 clients c'est
seulement à la suite du signalement de
mediapart que ses techniciens ont résolu
le problème en supprimant les fameuses
adresse permettant l'accès aux banques
de donner quelques leçons sont à tirer
de ces graves négligences tout d'abord
aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître ce site était pas homologué par
le ministère de la santé et n'avaient
pas fait l'objet d'un contrôle la
direction générale de la santé a
aussitôt réagi en rappelant la liste
limitée des entreprises certifiées le
ministère prévoit de sanctionner ce type
de débordements mais puisque français ce
n'était pas certifié comment at il pu se
connecter la plateforme de l'état
simplement en utilisant les identifiants
de ses clients pharmaciens et non les
siens encore une faille de taille xxl
dans le système puisque une entreprise
non homologué non professionnel de santé
peut accéder à ce serveur très sensibles
de l'état
secundo la plateforme si des mises à
disposition par l'état n'était pas
simple d'utilisation pour les
professionnels de santé et a fait
l'objet de critiques comme on peut en
concevoir un outil aussi peu adapté à
l'heure où les tests massifs sont une
des armes les plus puissantes pour
combattre le virus alors quelles peuvent
être les conséquences de cet accès libre
n'est sensible si personne d'autre que
la patiente lanceuse alerte et mediapart
n'a cherché à accéder aux données il n'y
aura aucune répercussion en revanche si
des individus malveillants ont pénétré
dans ce système ils pourront contacter
des personnes en se faisant passer pour
des organismes officiels
grâce à leur connaissance des
informations confidentielles une
personne se méfie - lorsque son
interlocuteur dispose de son numéro de
sécurité sociale par exemple il peut
penser qu'il s'agit bien d'une caisse
maladie ou d'un hôpital ils auront
tendance aussi à répondre favorablement
à des mails de pirates qui d'ailleurs
peuvent pirater des comptes à amélie et
de sécurité sociale chez france teste on
tente d'éteindre l'incendié avec un
arrosoir il existe selon eux aucun
élément qui permette de penser que des
informations personnelles de patients ou
de pharmacien est effectivement fuite et
pour eux cet incident est techniquement
clôturer mais désormais une ombre plane
sur la sécurité des stockages de données
de patients face à la multiplication des
acteurs et le manque de contrôle